this video is brought to you by danish
class 101 pod 101 and class 101 courses
are one of my favorite ways to start
learning a new language online
click the link in the description or
visit langfocus.com
danish class to give it a try finally
today we're going to talk about the
danish language so i can explore my
danish roots
no no i am danish
no wait my name is danish
uh yeah i can't say that
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today we're going to focus on the danish
language
today or just dense as it's called in
danish
there are around 6 million native
speakers of danish mainly in denmark
including greenland but also in the
state of schleswig holstein
in northern germany it's also an
official language in the faroe islands
though it's learned as a second language
there just like swedish and norwegian
danish is a continental north germanic
language it has historically formed a
dialect continuum with swedish and
norwegian
and on paper it's very similar to them
but when spoken it's normally quite
difficult for swedish and norwegian
speakers to understand because of its
complex phonology a common joke is that
danes sound like they're speaking with a
potato stuck in their throat
or with a mouthful of porridge that's
partly because lots of the phonemes that
swedish and norwegian speakers would
clearly pronounce
seem to be slurred or even disappear in
danish but as we'll see later
many of those pronunciation quirks are
systematic and at least to some extent
predictable the north germanic languages
all descended from old norse which
developed from proto-germanic by the 8th
century
some variation began to develop in old
norse and it diverged into old west
norse and
old east norse which diverged into old
danish and old swedish by around the
13th century
as i mentioned in my video on swedish
old east norse is sometimes referred to
as either runic swedish or runic danish
depending on its location
this name reflects the fact that it was
written in the runic alphabet
by the time danish had developed into a
separate language from swedish in the
13th century
the written language of denmark was
latin and danish was mainly written in
the latin alphabet
though it continued to be written with
runes to a limited extent
in the mid-14th century danish began to
be used as an administrative language
though the written language was not yet
standardized so dialectal variation
and different spelling choices were
evident in writing
and just like swedish and norwegian
danish vocabulary was significantly
influenced by low german during the
hanseatic expansion
in the 16th century latin ceased to be
the exclusive language of christianity
because of the protestant reformation
and the first danish bible was published
in 1550
as was the case with many languages of
europe this went a long way towards
making danish a literary language and
towards standardizing it
but during this time the characteristic
phonological features that
set danish apart from swedish and
norwegian were also developing
in the following centuries numerous
danish grammars were written as well as
an increasing amount of literature
in the 17th century the variety of
danish used by the danish chancellery
became the de facto standard language
and served as the basis for
these as standard danish is called today
one noteworthy feature of this variety
of danish was the uvular r
sound unlike the rolled r in other words
the alveolar r which is used in most
areas of sweden and norway
universal education increased literacy
and national broadcasting in the 20th
century
spread the standard language to every
region making the language
fairly uniform throughout the country
dialects are now mainly limited to
elderly speakers in certain areas
danish is well known for being difficult
to pronounce and difficult to understand
due to its relatively complex phonology
people often describe it as not being
clearly enunciated
one book that i've seen prefers the
euphemisms soft and
indistinct and many sounds become
reduced or dropped in danish
for example this word meaning product so
take a look at the spelling and imagine
what it sounds like
well here's how it sounds in danish
there is far from being a one-to-one
relationship between letters and sounds
you have to learn the sounds that
various letter combinations make too
as well as the way certain sounds change
depending on the other sounds
surrounding them
do you remember this phrase from the
beginning of the video
meaning red fruit pudding with cream pay
attention to the d
sounds the danish d is pronounced in a
few different ways
at the beginning of a syllable it sounds
like duh or maybe like
without aspiration it's pronounced in a
different way when it comes after a
vowel in a syllable coda
in other words it's not at the beginning
of a syllable this is the soft d
sound in many books and courses it's
described as a soft
the sound like in english the but it
really doesn't sound like that
listen to this example meaning fat
the soft d is often perceived as an l
sound
by non-native speakers it's typically a
velarized laminal alveolar approximant
rather than trying to wrap our heads
around what that is let's just think
about how to make a good attempt at
producing it
when you make a voiced the sound the tip
of your tongue is between your upper and
lower teeth
but when you make the danish soft d
sound the tip of your tongue touches the
back of your lower teeth
and as you're making the sound the rest
of your tongue kind of rises and moves
forward
bringing it close to the roof of your
mouth your tongue never fully contacts
the roof of your mouth
making it an approximant rather than a
fricative
d is also not pronounced after l or n
or before t or s for example
meaning an age sen meaning the devil
g is also soft at the end of words and
between
voiced sounds in a syllable coda that
means its place of articulation
opens up and it changes from a stop to
an approximant
it's almost silent or silent for example
meaning a choice and a meaning bake
g is also pronounced as one of the two
vowel elements in several diphthongs as
we'll see in a minute
the letter v is also pronounced as an
approximant not usually a fricative
for example the v is silent after l
for example meaning self and
meaning floor it's also silent after the
vowel u
and v is pronounced as the second
element in some diphthongs
as we'll see in a minute at the
beginning of words
r is pronounced as a voiced uvular
fricative
or a voiced uvular approximant at the
back of the throat
for example at the end of words it's
pronounced as a vowel
for example and that's also true
after a vowel in a syllable coda vowels
danish vowels can be either short or
long and many of them can be pronounced
more than one way depending on the other
sounds adjacent to them
for example when the letter a comes
before or after
r it's pronounced ah for example
in other contexts it's pronounced more
like a when it's a short vowel
and it's more like a when it's a long
vowel for example
meaning paint e is pronounced a
either as a short or long vowel it's but
can also be
either short or long after r and it can
be pronounced as a schwa
or become silent at the end of words
danish stands out amongst the
continental north germanic languages for
having lots of diphthongs
there are two categories those with e as
the second element
and those with oo as the second element
hi hi
how notice that there are many cases
when a combination of a vowel plus g or
v
represents a diphthong that's because at
least in some contexts they are
approximants
then because approximants are close to
vowels the vowel plus approximant
combinations become diphthongs
unlike swedish and norwegian danish does
not have pitch accent
but it does have phonemic stress accent
the meanings of some words are
distinguished by differences in stress
for example
one unique phonological feature of
danish that other north germanic
languages don't have
is called this is like a glottal stop
without complete closure of the vocal
cords
resulting in what's described as a
creaky voice it's phonemic and its
presence can distinguish words that
otherwise sound the same
for example meaning she versus
meaning dog
meaning me versus my meaning may as in
the month of may
it can appear in syllables with a long
vowel or in syllables with a short vowel
followed by a voiced consonant this
phonological feature
is not present in some dialects
specifically southern danish dialects
now let's look at some sentences in
order to examine some of the grammatical
features of danish
yes meaning i saw a film
word for word it's i saw a film the word
order is the same as in english
s-v-o in is the indefinite article
the definite equivalent of this sentence
is yeah
meaning i saw the film the definite
article is a suffix that attaches to the
end of the noun
unlike the definite article in english
that comes before the noun
danish has two genders common gender and
neuter gender
is a common gender now for our neuter
noun the article is
it's i saw a house
notice that the pronunciation of the
articles becomes reduced in full
sentences
since they're not emphasized as keywords
yes
i saw the house plural nouns also take
indefinite and definite endings but
rather than depending on gender they
fall into one of three noun classes
yeah so it's all film i saw two films
i saw the films this noun class takes no
suffix on the indefinite plural
and the suffix on the definite plural
yes so so i saw two houses yes
i saw the houses in this noun class the
indefinite form has the suffix
but pronounced like a schwa and the
definite form has the suffix
in this class the indefinite form takes
the suffix
and the definite form takes the suffix
oh no there are also some irregular
nouns with different plural forms
i saw the fantastic film word for word i
saw
the fantastic film when an adjective is
used in a sentence the definite article
suffix is replaced by a standalone
definite article that comes before the
noun
the common gender one is the neuter one
is
d the plural one is d for both genders
tomorrow he's flying to london word for
word it's tomorrow
fly he to london the sentences we saw
before followed svo word order but not
every sentence is svo
rather the continental north germanic
languages feature v2 word order
that means that if an adverb or another
element of the sentence comes first
the verb will come next and the subject
will come after the verb
in danish and the other north germanic
languages this applies to main clauses
but not to embedded clauses though in
icelandic it applies to both
before we saw the first person singular
subject pronoun
and here we see the third person
singular subject pronoun
danish personal pronouns are similar to
those of english except that the
equivalent of
it has both common gender and neuter
forms and there's a second person plural
pronoun
which standard english doesn't have of
course in vernacular english people have
different ways of expressing the second
person plural like you all
y'all you guys etc but none of those are
really part of the standard language
henry finishing covert he can't find his
suitcase
word for word it's he cannot find his
suitcase
this possessive scene is not on the
chart it's an additional third person
singular possessive adjective
and pronoun which indicates that the
subject of the sentence is the possessor
so this sentence means that he can't
find his own suitcase
in this sentence he did finance truther
the meaning is that he can't find a
different person's suitcase
sin is common gender but there's a
neuter gender equivalent
seeds and a plural equivalent seen there
are equivalents of these in swedish
and norwegian as well notice the
negative marker
which comes after the auxiliary verb in
this particular case
the english syntax is the same since we
say can't
or cannot but in many present tense
sentences in english we use do not
while danish doesn't use an equivalent
of do almost no languages do
in danish the negative always comes
after the verb
we don't eat meat how about the verb
itself
as in swedish and norwegian verbs are
not conjugated for person or number
so this present tense verb is exactly
the same no matter who the subject is
in the past it's always etc
regular verbs are divided into two
classes those which end in t
e and those which end in e-d-e species
eat speech eight who's remember
who still remembered henrietta
his suitcase wasn't found word for word
his
suitcase became not found this is a
passive sentence
the passive here is formed by using the
verb to become
plus the past participle meaning found
another way to form the passive is by
adding s to the active form for regular
verbs
or in this case e s sent found
sentence was found but this passive form
takes on a different meaning so this
would actually mean
existed so the form with you is the only
one to use here
he has only 50 euros in cash word for
word
he has only 50 euro in cash
notice the word for 50 in danish
danish has a very unusual way of forming
numbers from 50 to 100
which is not found in the other north
germanic languages they developed from
multiples of 20 rather than multiples of
ten
the word for fifty six means something
like
half three times meaning three times
twenty
minus half of twenty sixty is six
meaning three times three times twenty
seventy is
meaning half four times eighty is yes
meaning four times ninety years
meaning half five times in the
equivalent ordinal numbers
we can see the unabbreviated form of the
numbers which shows their etymology
50th health system since
is the genitive of which means times
but it's an archaic word the modern word
is
and its genitive form is
sixtieth sessions tune seventieth
hellfishes
tune atf fierceness tuner 90f
hell samson's tuner if you're familiar
with either of the other continental
north germanic languages then i'm sure
it's obvious
to you that danish is similar to them
for the most part
with some difference in grammar spelling
a little bit more difference in
vocabulary
and most of all differences in
pronunciation the phonological
developments that have taken place in
danish mean that
one phoneme can have a variety of sounds
depending on the other sounds that
surround it
and that the sounds often don't
correspond to the spelling of words
but hopefully you've seen that there are
some patterns to those differences and
that it's far from impossible to learn
danish pronunciation
especially for speakers of swedish and
norwegian who have trouble understanding
danish i think it would be pretty easy
to learn to understand it by learning
those patterns and then getting lots of
exposure to danish
the question of the day i think i've
asked a similar question before in
another video
but for speakers of danish how easy is
it for you to communicate with norwegian
and swedish speakers
are you able to adjust your speech so
that they can understand you
and norwegian and swedish speakers are
you able to communicate with danish
speakers
and other people what's your impression
of danish which of its features stand
out to you
i hope this has been an interesting and
entertaining look at the danish language
but if you want to develop actual skills
in the language then click the link in
the description
to visit danish class 101 or visit
langfocus.com
danish class it's the most extensive
danish course i've ever seen with
literally hundreds of lessons for
learners of any level
and the lessons get progressively more
challenging as your level improves
as the name suggests they're podcast
based lessons which is great for people
who like to learn using audio materials
and for people who want to learn on the
go
these days i try to focus much more on
audio materials than i used to
so that i can build my listening
comprehension and do my best to imitate
native pronunciation but class 101 and
pod 101 courses
offer more than just audio lessons they
have lots of video lessons as well as
downloadable books and pdf materials
so that you can get visual input and
explanations of all the language
introduced in the lessons
they also have audio recordings of the
individual words and phrases so you can
review them individually
and you can create vocabulary flash
cards that use spaced repetitions to
help you memorize the words more easily
they also offer quizzes to help you
review lessons word lists of the most
commonly used words and other features
for class 101 and pod 101 courses in
general i recommend using the additional
tools such as the downloadable lesson
notes and the spaced repetition
flashcards
to review and solidify what you learn in
each lesson before moving on to the next
one
for danish specifically i really
recommend you focus on the lesson
vocabulary words and their recordings so
that you can hear each individual word
clearly pronounced and
imitate it if you have an awareness of
the features of danish pronunciation
like those mentioned in this video
and then you practice imitating the
pronunciation of the individual words
while observing their spelling
that should be of tremendous help in
taking on danish phonology
i've never learned a language using only
a class 101 or pod 101 course but i'm a
member of several of their courses and i
regularly use them as part of my study
program
lots of content is free including all
new lessons which are free for the first
couple of weeks
and then if you want access to all the
content you can upgrade to a paid
account
i really recommend you check out
innovative language courses
whether for danish or one of 33 other
languages they offer
click the link in the description to get
a free lifetime account
i also want to give a big shout out to
all the lang focus patreon supporters
especially the top tier patrons whose
names are on the screen
check out patreon.com langfocus and
check out the benefits of the various
tiers
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice
[Music]
day
[Music]
you